now a little bit of good news better
news coming out of the House of
Representatives Nancy Pelosi has just
lost for gavel
and with great confidence in our caucus
I will not seek re-election through
Democratic Leadership in the next
Congress
Nancy Pelosi is out I love that was a
daily wire video of a superposition of
uh Nancy Pelosi at a bar and everything
well seeing Nancy she's gone so she's no
longer going to be the speaker of the
house because she's not in the majority
anymore and she is not going to run for
House minority leader which means
effectively she'll keep her seat in the
House of Representatives but Nancy
Pelosi is done
she is done as a major force in American
politics she held on for a very long
time now she is done now the Republicans
are taking over what are the Republicans
going to do well we've got an
announcement from representative James
Comer republican from Kentucky who says
they are going to waste no time
getting to investigate Hunter and Joe
Biden
this is an investigation of Joe Biden
the president of the United States and
why he lied to the American people about
his knowledge and participation in his
family's international business schemes
National Security interests require the
Committee conduct investigation and we
will pursue all avenues avenues that
have long been ignored committee
Republicans have uncovered evidence of
federal crimes committed by and to the
benefit of members of the president's
family these include
conspiracy or defrauding the United
States
wire fraud conspiracy to commit wire
fraud violation of the foreign agent's
registration act violations of the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act violations
of the trafficking victims protection
act tax evasion money laundering and
conspiracy to commit money laundering
the Biden family's business dealings
implicate a wide range of criminality
from Human Trafficking to potential
violations of the constitution in the
118th Congress this committee will
evaluate the status of Joe Biden's
relationship with his family's foreign
partners and whether he is a president
who is compromised or swayed by Foreign
dollars and influence I want to be clear
this is an investigation of Joe Biden
okay so I like the way he frames this he
says this is not just an investigation
of Hunter Biden who nobody really cares
about but it's an investigation of Joe
Biden right we see on Hunter Biden's
laptop he says 10 goes to the big guy so
is Hunter just off there on his own
making a bunch of money without any
knowledge of his father trading on his
father's name getting his father to
potentially make some phone calls
or is this corruption that implicates
Joe
I like it I think it's important to
investigate Hunter Biden I think it's
important to investigate Anthony fauci I
think it's even though Fati now is
quitting so that he hopefully doesn't
get investigated in his views I hope he
still does
we need to do all of this
however
I go back to those moms for
liberty-backed candidates at the school
board we need results
okay very often house panels don't do
anything there's lots and lots of
investigation and it amounts to nothing
when the Democrats do it there's the
January 6 investigation that's not going
to do anything
and then there's the Benghazi
investigation didn't do very much and on
and on and on
we need results
okay
if this investigation is not going to
end in Joe Biden or people very close to
him in orange jumpsuits
then just don't do it then spend your
time on other stuff it's it's very
frustrating to me that we spend a ton of
money sending people to Washington D.C
as conservatives and they can serve
basically nothing and as we saw this
week with the Republicans in the Senate
they don't they haven't they can't
conserve even the basic fundamental
political unit
and then we spend very little money
sending women to school boards and then
they actually get things done that
actually matter in Americans lives and
shape the minds of the Next Generation
so when I'm looking at those two things
I'm thinking okay maybe I'm not going to
write as many checks to the republicans
in Congress who don't do anything anyway
and I I am going to start writing my
checks to the school board candidates
who are actually getting things done we
need
results
right now head on over to expressvpn.com
Michael Knowles show sending data over
an unencrypted internet connection is
like sending a postcard your message is
wide open for the mailman and any other
nosy individual to see whenever you are
connected to an unencrypted internet
Network on your phone computer tablet or
TV you are sending countless pieces of
information out into the digital world
that can be seen and intercepted by
pretty much anyone a VPN or virtual
private Network creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the internet
it's like putting your postcard in an
envelope so that no one can read your
letter before it gets to the person that
you're sending it to expressvpn is the
VPN I trust to keep my data secure
expressvpn creates a secure unencrypted
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that hackers can't steal
your personal data your passwords your
financial details Etc hackers make
serious cash selling personal
information on the dark web but
expressvpn makes it easier than ever to
keep your information safe just fire up
the app click one button and you are
instantly protected
plus expressvpn works on all your
devices so you can stay secure on the go
secure your online data today at
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show and
get three extra months for free that is
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com
michaelenoll's show as the libs awful
sort of religion of leftism takes over
unfortunately
I'm sorry to say many so-called
conservatives are going along with it
this was so pathetic yesterday
Democrats in Congress
just proposed
a a further destruction of the family
the family has been very weakened
it's been weakened for 60 years now the
the left has done everything it can to
weaken the family
now they're trying to deal a death blow
and that would be through something they
euphemistically call the respect for
Marriage Act
the respect for Marriage Act would
codify the obergefell decision which
invents a new definition of marriage
completely contrary to the actual
definition of marriage that has
prevailed everywhere for all of human
history and it would codify it and go
further it would prohibit businesses
from following their conscience from
being Christian or Jewish or Muslim
though as a as a practical matter they
will only enforce this against
Christians they this sort of law would
make Jack Phillips a masterpiece cake
shop illegal if you don't want to
participate in a gay wedding that that
will be illegal now if you're a business
it's a radical radical redefinition of
the family which is the fundamental unit
of society
so I'm not surprised that the libs
peddle this they hate the family they
hate society and they want to destroy
the country
but I am disgusted that conservatives
would go along with it and a dozen of
them did these are the Senators who went
along with it there were a bunch of
congressmen in the house when this past
a while ago and then the Senators
yesterday went along with it to to
advance this legislation beyond the
filibuster which puts it on a fast track
to being passed Roy blunt
Richard Burr so Roy blunt from Missouri
Richard burr from North Carolina Shelly
capito from West Virginia Susan Collins
from Maine Joni Ernst from Iowa Cynthia
Lumis from Wyoming it's too bad I
actually like her but horrible horrible
judgment here Lisa murkowski from Alaska
Rob Portman from Ohio and of course Mitt
Romney from Utah
absolutely pathetic so these people
these conservatives
can't conserve anything they can't
conserve anything we joke about how all
these conservatives they can't even
conserve the women's bathroom they can't
conserve anything they can't conserve
the basic unit of society they just are
Democrats they just are liberals
and they're radical liberals they're
they're liberals further to the left of
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton in
2011. okay that's how radical they are
really really pathetic What is marriage
I get a lot of people just don't
understand this anymore marriage is the
lifelong communion of a husband and his
wife
for the good of the spouses and for the
sake of the generation and education of
children that's what marriage is
why can't two people who love each other
just get married
well they can but not all love is the
same and not all unions are the same I
love my grandmother I'm not going to
marry my grandmother
I love my friends I'm not going to marry
my friends
I love my co-workers I'm not going to
marry my co-workers
What is marriage marriage cannot be
redefined because marriage is not merely
a social construct or a sort of
political contrivance marriage is a
natural institution this is
defined by Aristotle defined by Saint
Thomas Aquinas as the natural state of
man man is a paring creature we are
canubial creatures even more than
political creatures and we are drawn to
propagate the species with our spouse
and to help one another
that's what marriage is so you cannot
redefine sexual difference is at the
very heart of marriage if you don't get
that
you don't get anything
as a conservative if you cannot conserve
the natural Institution
maybe one of the most fundamental
aspects of human nature
you can't conserve
anything
so why did these people vote for it why
did they vote for it
I suspect some because they're just
absolute disgraceful sellouts like Mitt
Romney but some
because they think well it's a lost
cause
it's a lost cause people support the
redefinition of marriage now so Michael
give up it's a lost cause that's what
they told us about abortion for 49 years
it's a lost cause Give It Up
oh come on it's a lost cause
and then it wasn't a lost cause you know
the rest of the show starts now
we have got a really important stuff
today this is fake headline Friday I
have been on an absolute tear Ben Davies
is so upset because I keep guessing the
fake headline I need your help to do it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]